hello freak one of the biggest
issues I think that people are having
with religion in the 21st century is
these areas where you're not allowed to
question and explore that things hit
these walls where this is God's will and
this is the way it is and in my mind
what we say that is just cold word for I
don't want to think about it right it's
so confusing too complicated terrifying
- terrifying and and that and or people
say and this amazes me I get people
whose creams like you will never
understand the origin yours you'll never
understand what love is science will
never ever explain love science will
never ever explain x4 what will and then
I say to them well that's incredibly
pompous statement because if you say
that science will never explain this you
must understand it because how do you
know that we'll never explain it we
never know what we won't be able to
explain until we try and maybe there are
things about our universe that we'll
never understand but we don't know until
we try you can never say upfront that
science will never explain this or that
because you haven't tried and in my
experience as a scientist I've been you
know I
there could be have been brick walls but
I've watched progressively those brick
walls crumble as we move around them or
we break them and it is so exhilarating
and that's why it's the greatest story
we're told it's so exhilarating to see
them knocked down and things you thought
we'd never understand remember one of
the forces nature a very prominent
physicist in 1960s early 1916 69 M it
will be a hundred years before we
discover understand this interaction
next year the theory came out and it's
so wonderful to see how the story
surmounts the biases and the
anticipation of individual scientists
that's the greatest story ever to over
told so far well what's ridiculous about
saying no one will ever figure anything
out is that what we figured out over the
last 200 years is monumental and then
human language has only been around for
forty thousand absolutely live another
fifty thousand years a hundred thousand
years as long as we don't as long as we
keep open inquiry you could imagine
movie I mean look we went through a few
hundred years of the Middle Ages where
the incredible in
query-based civil culture of the Greeks
was just forgotten I mean you know that
Greeks had determined the circumference
of the earth not only that it was round
but what its circumference was by simple
measurements that were then not accepted
because of dogma so we have to if we
want to progress we have to beware of
dogma how did they figure out the
circumference of the arrow it's really
neat I think it was a Aristarchus I
figure which of the quiz the Greek down
it's amazing well what he said was look
so in a certain time of day in a certain
time of the year the Sun is directly
overhead at 12:00 noon okay and in my it
so I look and I can tell that by looking
down a deep well and I see the
reflection of the Sun exactly in that
deep well ok so the Rays of the Sun
which are coming down in the same
direction towards the earth everywhere
it comes down to the ball but a hundred
miles away the well because the surface
is curved the well is pointing in a
little bit different direction so the
sun's rays come at a slightly different
angle so on this on this day I will
measure that the Sun is directly
overhead for me but I'll get my friend
100 miles away to measure the angle of
the Sun relative to the well and if you
that tells you that the earth is curved
and if you do the geometry you can work
out if the hundred miles of the Earth's
surface causes the sun's rays to
suddenly be at that angle how curved the
earth is and what the circumference of
the earth is it's plane geometry that in
principle any high school student could
do but when you say a hundred miles away
first of all how are they communicating
with this guy 30 miles away not
immediately but the guy writes it down
and there's a horse and they come and
compare notes lay and they use a sundial
to determine the time the sundial to
determine a time and and the 100 miles
in a Wade would there be a deviation at
all in the time a minute or two well
that yep but so to some accuracy you
right you get it wrong to some accuracy
right but they did pretty damn well they
came up with the circumference nearest
was darn close to the circumference of
the earth and so uh it's amazing that
they use these techniques so they were
just so confused and so curious about it
all they just tried to figure out what
it has got to be a way to figure this
out
well and they didn't and they weren't
they weren't forced with the dogma that
the earth is flat right as you I've told
today you were dealing with some people
who were still forced with that dog
it's very strange how do you feel about
that you know in 2017 it amazed but you
know nothing surprised not only that
gravity's not real and dinosaurs aren't
real and you know the people say gravity
are real I have a great solution but
it's a table building walk out the
window at 13th floor and test your ideas
and the great thing is do it before you
reproduce but it's a magnetism thing
they believe it's electromagnetism or
something like that so I'll ad people
down to the yeah that is we're going to
think so marinating here a magnet and
look at it as what happens as you're
falling to the earth well it's even more
hilarious is that they well we talked
about this before the podcast started
the Japanese weather satellite that
makes an image a full image of the earth
what is the name of that satellite again
Jamie it takes a full image of the earth
from 22,000 miles ago away people keep
saying in this Flat Earth theory thing
that there's no images of the earth in
full but they're all composite it's not
true it's not true there are images of
the earth that are taken every 10
minutes by this one satellite and
they're high-resolution you can you can
access them online anytime you want but
people see those and they want to think
they're fake but yet they believe
there's an ice wall around Antarctica
that you cross over and you fall to the
abyss where's this photo of the ice wall
when where is it or have they never well
how does someone fly from Japan you know
they don't believe that people can fly
around the world I've done it I've done
that they're all lying here's another
one
have they ever taught time zones why
their time zones of the earth is flat
why are the time zones the only reason
they're time they should go from New
York to LA and see you know what the
time is different that because I think
it's they don't know but they probably
think it's a human invention yeah but
you know the Sun is still shining in LA
when it's gone down in New York and they
can call their friends and check if the
earth was flat that wouldn't be the case
it's only the case because the earth is
curved I mean so those simple things
should should convince you but people
are willing to throw out evidence if
they have a belief that's really firm
and what I said before is we have to
realize the easiest perfect person to
fool is yourself so if you're not
willing to question your beliefs
especially those that you hold
particularly cherished beliefs in if
you're not willing to question those
you're not going to you're not going to
ever grow
yeah well that's a good way to put a
particularly cherish because I think a
lot of people do cherish these ideas
things like the earth being flat because
it gives them some sort of information
leg up on everybody I was something that
people don't know or makes them feel
better about themselves they may hate
gays because it makes them feel better
about not being gay or maybe they
they're gay yeah yeah yeah yeah you know
I mean we always worry about that
yeah so I I think we all that's what I
mean by being believing 10 impossible
things for breakfast we I don't want to
make fun of people because we all do
think of things to make us feel better
about ourselves it's part of being human
the psychological pit yeah yeah and so
we should be aware of those and I have
them and you have them and I don't
pretend I don't what I do try and do is
question them yeah we can all do that
and I don't I don't I understand why
people are believe certain things it's
not it and you can be you know what
again Richard Dawkins tells me about a
an astrophysicist he knows who during
the day you know studies objects in the
sky and and and looks at galaxies or
stars and measures that they're that
they're 12 billion years old or whatever
and then but yet he goes home at night
and and it's and and is convinced that
the earth is 6,000 years old so somehow
we can really do both yeah he knows a
guy I thought yeah and people can and
we're all capable of believing in two
mutually contradictory things at the
same time it's just the way we're built
and so how does this guy measure the
glue of these planets somehow it doesn't
affect his fundamental beliefs and it's
amazing it's true because we can all
believe things that are wrong and so it
doesn't mean they're stupid it doesn't
mean because this guy is apparently a
fairly accomplished astrophysicist it's
a psychological pizza but we all have
trap sorry so many people you know when
I talk about this I don't want to seem
pompous in the sense of saying all I'm
better or scientists a better science is
better because science helps us overcome
those pitfalls why do those pitfalls
exist though cuz because they obviously
evolution I would argue that they have
eleven evolutionary purpose that somehow
they allow if they didn't have an
evolutionary purpose then they wouldn't
been selected for right right there just
seemed to be some weird inclination or
some desire to expose secrets finds
entrance and know
them yeah it's nice well but on the
other end that's great let's exploit
that right discovering secrets is about
is discovering mysteries rights covering
mysteries is what motivates it is to do
sign so let's put it in positive light
we all want to solve puzzles we all want
to understand something and maybe be the
first one to understand it we all want
to access information maybe and make us
feel special for doing it well that's
the reason I do science right it's not
right save the world it's because I
really want to know understand I mean
and it's nice to be the first person to
maybe understand stuff it's gratifying
for your ego it's and we are driven you
know I'm by ego and and let's not
pretend otherwise
right but you I think you're talking
about measurable things and elements and
things you could sort of expose and
explain but what these people seem to be
really obsessed with is people lying
about stuff and covering up secrets
about like the earth being flat or
chemtrail yeah they like to believe
there's a conspiracy yeah and then
Canaries are very very attractive yeah
because it because and I you know I
don't I'm not a psychologist so to what
I say here is just a speculation but the
world doesn't care what you believe and
it doesn't treat you fairly right right
and that's it's just a fact the world
doesn't treat me fairly doesn't really
it doesn't give a damn about my
well-being or okay so hey I'm being
treated unfairly isn't it better for me
to think that someone is actively being
unfair to me then just assume it's just
the way it is because then I can blame
it and so I tend to think conspiracy
theorists tend to say you know the
things I don't like there's a real
reason for it it's not an accident it's
not just haphazard it's not anything and
it you know it's I've lost my job
because there's got to be a reason
there's got to be a villain there's got
to be someone making it happen just like
the reason we burn witches right because
there were storms or there wasn't you
know there wasn't crops that year and a
lot of people say it's an interesting
historical theory which i think is seems
quite plausible to me that when Newton
discovered the laws of gravity universal
law of gravity it contributed to the
ending of birth the burning of witches
why not said that was immense the
burning of witches I thought they
drowned the most
well had they hung a lot of them too
they drown them whether I don't care
whether it's burning they killer
understand okay they blamed crops they
blame the bad things and then when
Newton discovered that even the planets
are affected by the same laws that an
apple is there's a universal laws it
meant that physical effects had physical
causes and when bad things happen
there's a physical reason there's not
someone you can blame mmm and and
witches or whatever and so there's a lot
of arguments that suggest that that kind
of development in physics led to the end
of blaming people for those for bad
crops or or for bad things happening but
I think that's the kind of thing when we
want to find someone to blame rather
than just saying the universe doesn't
give a about me and anybody
interested in this is a really
fascinating subject but the whole Salem
witch trial thing and there there's a
lot of really convincing evidence it
seems to point towards her got poisoning
that there was some a late freeze and
that this particular type of fungus grew
on some of their wheat that makes her
got which is a very very LSD like
properties and I think these people
thought they were being bewitched
because they're being contaminated it's
a great idea you know again I don't know
the evidence for it but it's interesting
now it is fast and we always I think
behind that is is I know we've all had I
mean I think what we're seeing are
extremes of characteristics that we all
have I think many of us assign blame
when we shouldn't when I lose my keys
sometimes I see them out where do you
put my wife where did you put the keys
right and then I learned very quickly
that I should have said that
and and so I think it's it's just an a
it's a characteristic of being human and
accepting it as a characteristic of
being human doesn't diminish us and but
what's really great is we can understand
that and try and work and and try and
figure out ways to avoid those pitfalls
[Applause]
[Music]